angela what is the part of the child
custody system that enrages you the most
i just think that
there's a lot of different components of
it and you know that's what i found in
making this movie that it's not just
you know child custody it goes
deeper like parent alienation all of
these components but i think what really
bothers me is that
people go
there for help whether it's for support
or whether it's there for
you know
uh just dissolving the marriage amicably
and
i'm not sure that each case is handled
with compassion
if that makes sense and i think there
there should be more
education i think there should be more
um
alternatives to stay out of court
because it's just
a revolving door you're going out one
and coming back in another so the system
kind of just
operates on itself
for a long time without
maybe saying you know why don't you guys
get therapy or go back to a marriage
counselor even if you're not going to be
together co learn how to co-parent do
some different things and
i thought
when i was doing this movie i saw a lot
of signs
of
i don't know how to explain it it's just
like they
they kind of fed the fire
if that makes sense it was like okay
we'll take care of that we'll we'll fix
that the county's involved now we'll
make sure everything goes right you know
and i've seen cases
off the record where the couples agree
and they have settled
on the side with their lawyers or
whoever and they're happy they're
thinking that that's going to work and
they get in front of the county or
whoever the administrator is he said no
that doesn't work for us
you know how devastating that is not to
the people that are there but to their
kids
because they've worked it out
they've said we are going to take care
of this for our family and now you've
got this person that has no clue
except that the child is
a number and a name on a piece of paper
there's no way we know the interest of
the child we're going to do this and
we're going to take care of that
and you know unfortunately what happens
you know we've got a suicide rate that's
the largest in the country we have
incarceration of young kids that's the
largest in the country right we've got
all of these numbers that show
that the component of a single parent
home is harder than
two people
so
i just
think that
if this movie is not politically
correct and it's got to go against the
grain all the time and i'm hoping it
just brings that awareness that we kind
of create dialogue
that we can talk about things and maybe
nobody's going to be happy with the film
but hey it's there it's not much you can
do now